so I know you're shooting in Vancouver
Canada and you're working with the
Canadian is what was that experience
like well y'all really nice it's that uh
that cliche is true unfortunately no
it's so fortunate it's awesome it's
super cool and what I did realize the
biggest thing I knows was you actually
do have different accents so Americans
like they are very different it feels
like listening to like it in a different
country for real though like that accent
is so different
okay so then I'm gonna challenge you to
say something in a Canadian accent what
is what is Tierra says sorry sorry Siri
Siri she says like Siri or something
like that saying all the time like sorry
she's like Gloria yeah she's like she
just says a little things that are like
kind of hilarious there and then I might
follow her and then she gets angry at me
but yeah so different to Americans
Americans like way more harsh and like
hard arse and like you know I mean but
you've mastered that accent as well
Boston
we're just super no I I watched the
kissing booth and I'm knowing they oh
really and I was like when I found out
it was like holy cow yeah that like
years in the making
yeah yeah when I was 14 I decided that
if I was to go to America I wasn't gonna
have the issue of not being able to do
an accent so I listened to American
radio and and the other thing too is all
our media is American like films TV
music it's all American it's not like
Americans have a ton of like Australian
people talking in their ear all the time
so I would just copy the radio I found
like an international radio station and
when I was driving home from school or
something I would just say everything
they were saying oh and also Eminem I
listened to a lot of Eminem so
originally my accent was like dog and
cat and have it there was like really
like dad it was like really aggressive
and sometimes that still comes through
but I've made it a little more like
California and Universal I suppose
so like you're saying listening like
listening to the radio in Australia and
you're in LA and you're doing all these
films and if you had like what has been
your pinch me moment or is this kind of
it like have you kind of realized all of
this that's I mean it's all it it's it
would have been it would have been like
getting the phone call from our manager
about the kissing booth was like drop to
the floor in tears kind of thing but now
it's like you don't really get it I'm
gonna have to take like some crazy trip
to the mountains and luck decompress my
entire soul to like to really like to
really accept it cuz right now it's just
a ride and it's just like it's it kind
of feels like the norm but I'm also well
aware that it is not and that it then it
can change in a heartbeat so I'm just
kind of like just trying to do like good
work now and it's it successful it's
crazy it's ridiculous man oh yes we can
go and do it together right now like
this is bonkers it's absolutely nuts
you're saying kind of you need to escape
to get grounded to keep grounded who is
there somebody in your life that kind of
reminds you oh for sure my mom my mom is
like my mom's my best friend in the
whole world and she's she has like well
my mom my sister my brother my dad I
feel like they are all like they have
wants just it definitely has the answers
of the universe I don't know why she
hasn't told me yet but she knows exactly
what is happening in the world and
that's the way if I go home and I spent
like four weeks at home set I'm like
absolutely set so I'm trying to get home
more and more often now back to back to
Brisbane very nice for you for for
kissing booth when you had signed on to
do the film did you think it was gonna
be the success that it has been and I
thought people would like it but
definitely not on the scale that it's on
I mean he was saying was like one of the
most watched movies in the world at the
time that he came out and that's like
that's ridiculous but it's kind of cool
because I think it's gonna I think it's
gonna make a shift in sort of the way
everything's going cuz it's very simple
and it's very like very happy and very
normal they're not trying to be you know
this incredibly dense thing I think
that's going to make a change
in like back to the way that things were
you know back when wrong these teen
rom-coms but like will life it did well
they did exactly what the director set
out to do which is a bit of a testament
to him and you met a lovely lady yes I
met a lot of lovely ladies and so and
Joey's like so so cute you guys are
adorable
yes she's bad as mine Instagram um when
did it's really funny I always found it
really funny was there a moment kind of
on set when you were like this is not
just acting no no we're all just Brewer
just best mates and it's kind of like
all of us Joel joy and I and then ever
on the crew is kind of just like it was
like a chance it was just life man life
life happens yeah it's cool I couldn't
say there's an exact moment I don't know
I have no idea man
I remember these things not okay um so
she come to visit you like while you're
in sadly yeah she came to Vancouver
which was super cool super nice I was a
bit of a surprise which was nice
yes he's a legend